my name is Helene Engler and I am the
science writer for the Explorer's guide
to biology at the science communication
lab
I used to be a butterfly biologist and
teach undergraduate college biology
and my entire background in research in
teaching in Science Education and also
in journalism have prepared me really
well for my role
as a science writer I am from Long
Island New York and I grew up in a Beach
town called Massapequa and I did grow up
in a sciency family
I wasn't I didn't do a lot of hiking and
collecting butterflies and chasing
insects like some of my colleagues that
came later
but I grew up in a beautiful place with
natural preserves and parks and I had a
wonderful childhood I don't think I was
born a scientist like a lot of
scientists feel uh if anything I was
born a dancer because I've been dancing
through life since I was five years old
I was a really shy kid and
um science came really late to me in
life
I did have a third grade teacher that
told my mom that she thought
Helene's going to be a scientist so
maybe she planted the seed or saw
something that I didn't I got really
interested in science during High School
I remember being really good in biology
and chemistry and I I remember excelling
in those subjects
and I think for me science was a choice
I think that
I chose to become a scientist because it
was kind of a refuge for me I I think it
was a way for me to find a way to
understand the world that wasn't always
easy or normal
and it gave me a dream and a passion
so I actually went to Adelphi University
I got a Bachelor of Science in biology
and everybody who was a biology major
was pre-med
and I I don't know that idea just didn't
settle right with me I wanted to be
different maybe but I think I became a
scientist when
the summer of my junior year I took a
field course in primary ecology and
conservation in Costa Rica
through the school for field studies and
it was there that I met Mary Baker one
of the assistant professors on the
course
and she was documenting for the first
time
something called fur washing behavior in
capuchin monkeys they would get to this
Citrus Grove they take the fruits bite
them open and rub them like crazy all
over each other like in a fur bathing
Frenzy
and they did this right before they
moved into a riparian
river-based habitat where there were
lots of insects and parasites so this
just blew my mind here the monkeys were
self-medicating
they were using the citronella juices to
repel insects and parasites and that was
the moment I went back to Adelphi and I
told my advisor I was going to become a
scientist
and I got interested in the field of
chemical ecology which is how
chemicals influence interactions between
animals and plants then I moved to
Austin and did a PhD in biology studying
how butterflies overcome cyanide poisons
in their host plants and then I did a
postdoc at MD Anderson Cancer Center and
I was studying the role of aloe plant
sugars and how they can prevent
possibly prevent skin cancer
so the greatest thing about my job is I
get to wear multiple hats I get to not
only write
great you know college education
curriculum that hopefully will inspire
the next generation of students but also
I get to interview really cool sciences
and document the the real stories of how
science is done and hopefully we are
creating curriculum that will not only
Inspire students but maybe show students
that anybody can go into science
regardless of your background regardless
of whether you grew up collecting bugs
or dancing
anybody can become a scientist